just before dawn the rumors started
spreading and so did the fire
[Applause]
protesters set their defenses ablaze
convinced the police were here inside
Polytechnic University they're cornered
and are spent police control every exit
and they've threatened to open fire with
live ammunition
the protesters hid themselves behind
walls of fire all summer and now autumn
they've been saying if we burn you burn
with us that was not how today would go
today was about running some protesters
cast aside the black uniform they tried
to slip past the police in small groups
undetected plain clothes protesters
but a bigger group tried to break the
siege directly petrol bombs ahead of the
battle column bricks as covering fire
it was a desperate procession soon under
a shroud of tear gas they were beaten
back
forced to retreat their ever more
vulnerable fortress breakout became a
rout so what do you do now the police of
present use live ammunition real bullets
are you afraid afraid in any time first
we should not give up easily because we
are fighting for our freedom so now they
had two options stay and fight and go
down at least with an ostentatious bang
or take your chances on the run and risk
meeting the police waiting at every turn
this was a university built into a
fortress now it is a lonely husk it's no
one here it's very quiet this is the war
protesters built not that long ago it's
been taken down this really feels like
the end the siege at Poly you may be
near its end but the battle for Hong
Kong still rages Tom Cheshire Sky News
Hong Kong